hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play 1916 Danner
wouldn't that can't that wouldn't be
can't click Darrin Darrin on but can't
click I apply way off there but anyway
this is a small indie game that's based
off of World War one and dinosaurs I'm
not exactly sure
haha I don't know but anyway so flare
rifle gasps Mack interactive hole to
take flesh haha okay hi I'm very
intriguing lair Laden
in the delayed okay alright then I don't
know what I saw there in the distance
wha-what the hell was that
how very cinematic oldie time I feel not
many people knew that actually back in
1916 everybody saw in black and white
and it was really fuzzy so I'm assuming
I need to find a ladder where's my rifle
hello oh I got hands well I got a body
revolutionary I like those sounds Wow I
think someone's died there's a dead body
over there oh that was a dinosaur I knew
it I saw a screenshot with a dinosaur in
it do what ahh I took your foot gimme
wait hand sweetie hidden field in now
that's a raptor throw the guy's thrown
an arm the Brannon leave Stan Fortin d
dina Soren haben du Nord lick and till
dinner Hernan grabinger rebooted organ
girlfriend governor so I apologize to
all the German watching right now J
listen Doug and Morgan Bergen spiriting
come soon ich weiß nicht risin moon if
Norfolk I'm so sorry with North American
ok this is not how I remember World War
one
I see it does Lucy and Lindy did you
what guy hell that was a freaking Dino
sons
can I have those but I got a flair this
way mom get that click oh hey hey oh
dear okay son ooh oh my boy another dead
body please give me your flesh can I
have Oh No this reminds me of like the
intro movie to the Starcraft give me
your flesh
you didn't exactly look good
ah I saw you
ah get out of here
what I have can't be in here please take
that thank you
yard bullets - bullets disk Welton
disclaiming fusion oh god I'm so sorry
Germans my rival knock them John
guideway don't it grandpa Falls one
Dana's befallen in look if Erin doesn't
die Mahorn in hockey tainted and leaving
this new tier is that mother crying
someone was writing to their mummy baby
okay
this latter where am I oh god I'm over
there oh I'm in such a wrong place
we've gotta get some okay I gotta get
from the bunker I got to go back I
must've made a wrong turn
keep wanting to look right so basically
I go out this door turn left go straight
turn left right right and then it's
pretty much a straight shot such through
suiting music okay codes come out the
bunker go straight down that path left
right right left left right left
straight down this path hi beard I know
your boom huh what I thought [ __ ] Oh
ah don't need me no aah
with that oh the phone on slow bone
myself oh wow I'm like some sort of
armor died oh Jesus oh that was it that
bike that my exit giving ah I got
munched
that's fair
this game gives me the heebie jeebies
not so much terrifying but just the
heebie-jeebies
my health said it's like made out to be
a horror movie I know okay I started in
the same spot so if I can just find my
way back to where I was from there okay
the gun didn't seem to do jack doodlee
give me a body part enough take that no
give give give give give
thank you and they left last time and it
was the correct choice why don't I just
climb out I'm hot no it's a leg ah but I
will take a left here
Luisa
I doesn't sound good can't I have more
than one layer on Hyman strivin Gaiden
Jim fosston so why are these dead bodies
still here it's a question okay
Louis the bunkers over there so probably
the right way I don't know exactly where
I am I'm kind of bone darn I knows Oh
what ngahau what is wrong with you buddy
hey buddy quit dancing there and what's
your deal man
what deal seriously what is your deal
you're freaking me out
dude you're dude you're freaking me out
man watch with your hands and feet why
are they glowing where your feet so
small what God get out of here Culley
hell man that's that's freaky gonna
Ricky good guy that's a dead guys in one
weirdo
uh we'll hey Mia what's in will hey Mia
Oh gasps gasps gasps is in will hey Mia
Snuggies
scheisse Healy to get the gas mask on
siren I've been told that I look like
the medic from tf2 and my last name fish
box are practically practically another
successful procedure oh but uh how did I
not notice you and I think I need that
ooh ah
no take that leg I'm gonna get this leg
give me your leg put whatever okay go
back to the gas area I don't know if
there's like a cool down sprinting Wow
oh I'm going the wrong way no I got it
the right way
okay be me got me out gasps ah no how do
I put on the gas bag g8 there we go
oh I'm not gonna make it oh I am not
gonna make it good job Jess stop Oh
coming through liter liter that ladder
Peter they didn't fine annexed Alton oh
ah don't be crashing I mean they'll even
hooked in father's comminuted I'm gonna
make it oh that I know
did I did I die
I did i I won I won hmm um I'm not
exactly sure what happened there I think
I made it it's kind of hard to see
because it was so ah ah oh so freaked
out was parasha
oh yeah I could do it all see the
credits that's a lot of people working
on this this game man if that was it
that was sounds really short I mean it's
not like randomly generated at all so I
think I just like blew past it I think
from pure luck that I made it through
that but anyway I think that's the end
I'm not mistaken Oh
special thanks danke feelin danke
Zurich I do apologize to all the Germans
fur and anyone who speaks German for my
incredible rendition of German in those
notes they're controlling noblest lethal
Targa's mass Kappa sprint Laval girlist
interaction hold need it for a tie got
good cussed kid Stan rune okay sorry
once again I'm I'm so sorry I apologize
as I make fun of your language I just ha
ha ha I am German I am half German so
that's probably even worse anyway I just
say quit now anyway so anyway that was
really fun I'm actually kind of sad that
I made through it then I got through
through quickly because I was hoping
that it would be a little bit more and I
could help play it again but if I beat
it in there's nothing different then ah
there's no real point so but anyway that
was really cool for what it was I mean
there's the the bass is there for
another game I mean obviously it's all
built there and it looks really good for
what it was I don't know what was up
with the twitchy guy but either way that
was great thank you so much David Adler
tobias Cobb Thompson
Martin Blackland rums rasmussen
Patterson Sorensen de-ice hassled magrav
Thomas just dissing Celt Neeson
I really have Stylinson Benjamin Maruti
Magnussen is everything and it doesn't
Simon liebe wrestling make it Mikkel nor
felt Morten loon soulguard
okay thank you guys so much I think I'm
done oh there's a Jensen Klaus Rosalind
Indymedia is the mister not if I've gone
Scottish I've got four amazi Kristensen
okay Messi mas Johanna tapped out that's
a weird name okay alright I'm done I'm
done making fun of German so thank you
all so much for watching let me know
what you thought of this I mean very
interesting if these guys who made this
have done anything else I would
definitely be interested in seeing that
or if I miss something else that I need
to go back and see please let me know so
thank you all so much for watching check
the annotations for more videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye